you a played storm in x-men apocalypse
and you of course playing the the
younger storm is when they go back in
time so it's the rule originated by
Halle Berry yes okay so no pressure
they're not and you played yeah you
played so I think we have a picture here
of you as form fantastic look I love
thank you I love the Mohawk I actually
shaved my whole head you did that yeah
killed Bill Hader the you know I'm
curious about something you did a lot of
stunt work on the film and I'm wondering
is that stuff fun I I would think it
would be fun to do stunt work it is
really fun that you know for me it's
nice to like go to like hit someone and
have them to like really act like it
hurt you know so that feels really warm
and fuzzy on the inside but what people
don't tell you in what Halle did like an
amazing job at when she was acting as
storm is this is gonna sound really bad
dude that's okay okay your vagina falls
asleep okay when you're in that harness
and you're flying around you are
completely numb from the waist down like
you can just start hitting it nothing
you know what it feels like to have like
no feel down I've put other vaginas to
sleep but I don't know you know when you
started that sense I didn't know what
you and then you're like oh the harness
yes the harness so you have to float
because storm floats in the air feet in
the air
so there's no blood flow and then yeah
it's wrapped around your thighs and
around your waist so it's just kind of
like squeezing your vagina yeah yeah and
like I said Holly just made it look so
natural and easy and she's just you know
going up and killing it and I'm over
here like dying I have a guy that's like
my badge man and I'm like bro bring me
down
there's so many people right now who are
thinking that's a job you get right now
maybe a bad people scamming the credit
to that movie looking for okay it's it's
not an easy job you have to have really
extensive credentials to be x-men's
badge Minh yeah it's one word are you in
the Union sir no I'm not then hands off
that badge this this got bad real fast I
tend to do that to people
Wow okay so you know I also noticed
about storm and now I can't think about
anything else but what I noticed that
storm uses her hands a lot to shoot you
know lightning bolts yeah out of her
hands and I would think that's gonna
take a lot of I don't know faith and
commitment as an actor because when
you're doing it nothing's happening how
do you do that nothing it's all pure
imagination and when I first got the job
I was like alright I got to come up with
the moment in which I just bow
you know and every time I did it I felt
like I look like an idiot look I was
like no and I was like in the mirror and
I was like grappling with it and I was
like alright Alex now every time you get
frustrated like you have to get this
right because people are gonna be like
she was cool but like every time she
shot lightning bolt she looked like she
was having like a stroke or like a brain
yeah I don't want that I wanted to look
good you weren't good so every time I
got frustrated I just like my dog pees
on a rope are you kidding me
so it's someone like is like honking at
me to run a yellow light and I Drive
like an old lady and I'm like get off my
ass
I'm a big fan I'm a big fan of the x-men
movies I'm gonna watch that one again
knowing what you're thinking about it's
gonna change everything I can give you
like the full-on insight uh my vagina
hurts Joey and I'm really frustrated so
let me just use it yeah you channel that
oh yeah you got to man because otherwise
you're just gonna be sitting there like
yeah yeah yeah that's not a good look
for storm honestly it's not that's like
a wedgie kind of look you don't want
that
you